the mystery behind Ray's parentage is
buzzed around and Star Wars fans Minds
are since director JJ Abrams of force
awakens introduced us to Daisy Ridley
scrappy jakku Bourne scavenger we
learned a very mysterious force vision
that Rey's parents orphaned her as a
child though audiences never learn their
names or saw their faces who are they
Ryan Johnson's our last Jedi offered up
an answer if Adam drivers kylo Ren is to
be believed Rey's parents waiting
significant at low life Junkers who sold
her for drinking money but apparently
that's not what abrams had in mind when
he was considering how to answer the
question of rates parentage according to
actor simon pegg who played unkar plutt
in the force awakens abraham's plan was
different than what we saw in the last
Jedi peg hinted Abraham's intentions on
MTV correspondent Josh Horowitz is happy
sad confused podcast I know what JJ kind
of intended or at least what was sort of
being chucked around I think that's kind
of been undone slightly by the last one
there was some talk about you know it
was a kind of relevant lineage for her
go but I honestly don't know and I don't
know if anybody knows there was still a
ton of theories floating around but
whether Abrams meant for the trilogy to
eventually reveal Rey as a descendant of
the Skywalker clan or a member of the
Kenobi family tree or something else
altogether remains a mystery but pegs
comment reveals at the very least that
Abrams intentions weren't in line with
Johnston's later handling of the
parentage question still thistle hinges
on the assumption that Johnson intended
kylo ren's explanation to be truthful
there's evidence to the contrary
Johnson previously revealed that
anything still open when it comes to who
Rea really is and where he truly came
from just as Johnson took over the story
from Abrams after the force awakens
Abrams is grabbing the baton and
stepping back into the director's seat
for episode 9 Abrams may very well into
what was revealed in the last Jedi
delivering a twist that allows his
original vision for Rey's origins
whatever that may be to come full circle
after all a kylo Ren may just have lied
and told a clearly powerful Rey that
she's a nobody from a family of filthy
junk traders to get her to join him in
his twisted galactic conquest the truth
may be a whole lot more hopeful and will
hopefully be revealed when Star Wars
Episode nine is released on December
20th 2019
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe
to our youtube-channel Plus check out
all this cool stuff we know your love
today
[Music]